hallo herzlich willkommen in meiner
kochwelt wir werden heute abend grillen
und deswegen bereite ich gleich ein paar
salate zu und einer meiner lieblings
salate ist der kartoffelsalat von dem
habe ich ganz viele verschiedene
variationen aber am besten schmeckt mir
so die türkische variante und die
deutsche variante türkisch heißt bei mir
der wir dann mit zitrone und mit öl
angemacht kommt eis und so weiter mit
rein
das zeigt sich in einem anderen video
und heute möchte ich erst die deutsche
variante machen mit essig und öl und
zwiebeln und alles was sie hat noch
rumsteht und ich zeige mich jetzt einmal
kurz die zutaten und dann starten wir
auch direkt also ich brauche ein
bisschen öl entweder nimmt ihren mais öl
oder sonnenblumenöl dann ein kilo
kartoffeln des teams fest kochende das
eignet sich super für salate etwa an
geholfen teelöffel sind ich habe ich
noch vier esslöffel essig dann ein paar
gewürzgurken mit zwiebel bis zwölf
wasser als und paprikapulver und eine
rote paprika und später hole ich noch
ein bisserl frische kräuter von der
terrasse und ich hab jetzt zuerst die
kartoffeln genommen ich habe sie bereits
ab gekocht habe mich jetzt wirklich
schneller geht
aber ich habe die genommen hat sie
rundum eingeschnitzt also einmal somit
messe und dann kommen sie einfach in
heißes wasser und weisen so lang gekocht
bis sie eben gas sind meine sind jetzt
wie gesagt schon abgekocht und sehen so
aus und wenn ich halt jetzt mein messer
reingeht und sind sie halt schön weich
und jetzt gehe ich die ganz kurz unter
dem kalten wasser abschrecken dann kann
ich sie nämlich besser schälen und es
macht mir einfach kurz zusammen
das einfach kurz ab diesem und dann mit
kaltem wasser abschrecken und so las ich
jetzt kurz ausdampfen und so in 15
minuten geht es dann weiter geht sind
sie etwas abgekühlt und da verbrenne ich
mir halt nicht die hände und die
kartoffeln fahren auch nicht so schnell
auseinander
jetzt müssten normalerweise ganz einfach
gehen diese haut abzuziehen
vor allem weil man es auch eingesetzt
haben und kalt abgeschreckt haben
aber ich sehe es funktioniert doch so
gut also wenn man die kartoffelsorte
geht es besser bei annett aber man
kriegt es ja auch so ganz schnell runter
es geht auf jeden fall einfach
die kartoffeln geschält und ich habe sie
einfach da vorne wissel abgestellt und
in der zwischenzeit kann ich mich schon
mal um die zwiebel und um die paprika
kümmern denn die werden jetzt gewürfelt
so dann nehme ich jetzt hier vorne diese
wurzel david drin
ja ich mich immer daran mich deckel
nicht richtig drauf hat und die ganze
zwischen dann in der küche gelandet aber
sowas passiert hat jetzt gebe ich grad
so etwa 3 4 esslöffel olivenöl in die
pfanne und brate diese zwiebelwürfel
jetzt an
dadurch bekommen sie ein besseres aroma
und man kann den kartoffelsalat länger
aufheben
bei etwa mittlerer hitze und in der zeit
kann ich auch schon mal die paprika
gleich würfeln
ich habe inzwischen jetzt auch schon mal
sekunden entscheiden geschnitten und von
habe ich vergessen zu erwähnen er
braucht noch wasser und braucht noch ein
bisschen früher denn das bringt bisserl
würze mit rein
also ich habe jetzt hier etwa 250
milliliter wasser reiche geben gebe auch
noch brühe mit rein und teelöffel ich
nehme da immer welche ohne hefeextrakt
und ohne geschmacksverstärker könnten
aber auch selber machen kann ich mich
auch mal video zeigen dass ich das kurz
aufkochen und in der zeit kann ich schon
mal die kartoffeln in scheiben schneiden
denn die sind ja schön abgekühlt genau
dann mache ich es nämlich ganz kurz und
dann hat das auch gleich fest
also bei mir sind die kartoffel jetzt
ein bissel zerfalle denn meine
kartoffeln sind um ihnen noch heiß das
heißt wenn er wirklich wollt das ist
wirklich schöne tolle kartoffelscheiben
beiden müsst ihr wirklich warten bis er
abgekühlt sind oder ihr könnt auch so
machen dass es sie vor dem kochen
bereits in scheiben schneidet und dann
kocht und dann einfach komplett abkühlen
lassen sind sie erst mal schneller durch
und zweitens zerfallen sind so aber bei
mir ist nicht schlimm weil da schmeckte
trotzdem und ich mag ins bild group gebe
ich noch die gurkenscheiben mit drauf
und gibt auch gleich die zwiebel mit der
brühe trübe und dass es dann erstmal
einziehen
bevor ich dann den rest mit dazu gebe
also noch ganz heißt übergeben
jetzt ganz leicht vermengen dass
wirklich alle kartoffeln mit der brühe
auch bedeckt sind und dann lasse ich das
jetzt erstmal einziehen das dauert ein
paar minuten und danach stellen wird im
salat blech fertig
mein salate schön durchgezogen
schneller geht es übrigens wenn er die
zwiebeln und die gemüsebrühe getrennt
voneinander wahr macht und dann zuerst
die früher rein gibt die geht dann
einfach viel schneller in die kartoffeln
rein wie wir jetzt noch öl mit dabei ist
aber ich will jetzt einfach besser
geschirr spare und habt das zeug macht
ging jetzt auch dauert nur länger
und jetzt mache ich den salat fertig und
zwar kommt da jetzt noch es sich mit
leib und senf und ich berührt einfach
bisserl senf essig damit sich das gleich
schöner verteilt und gebt dann noch ein
bisschen salz mit ryan dunn ist ein
bisschen sparsam sein weil ich habe
schon gemüsebrühe mit drin
und damit es eben nicht zu versalzen
wird es gleich noch mit drin auf ich
gebe jetzt auch schon mal treffer rhein
etwas paprikapulver habe jetzt ein süßes
paprikapulver ich weiß ich würde es
nämlich immer ein bisschen zu scharf und
diesmal denke ich an meine mitmenschen
und jetzt einfach meine eigene teller
scharf bisschen salz dann gleich noch
die paprika würfel mache ich jetzt mal
nicht alle artikel und auch aufhebe
einmal durchführen sind halt immer schön
wenn man so ein bisserl noch farbe mit
drin hat deswegen finde ich die rote
paprika darin echt schön
so möchte es sich mit dem senf sie diese
unappetitliche aus aber ich hab einfach
ein größerer teller nehmen könne
wenn jetzt einfach gut durchmischen und
im prinzip ich dann auch schon fertig
also man kann jetzt noch schnittlauch
nehmen nämlich nur zum servieren so
wissel zum anrichten
ansonsten ist das jetzt echt gut den
salat könnte übrigens so gerne auch 1-2
tage aufheben im kühlschrank am besten
weil die zwiebeln ja auch angebraten
sind und eben das dann nicht so recht
auch im prinzip war das mein
kartoffelsalat rezeptbuch hat kommt
vielleicht von der arbeit heim dann habe
ich das gleich schon mal fertig für ihn
und brachte uns gleich noch ein bisserl
was mit dazu
zum grillen und ja wenn jetzt rezept
nach nach machen wollt geht einfach auf
meinen blog auf sales - blog.de
da gibt's noch mal die genauen zutaten
angaben
und wenn ihr gerne möchte dass ich euch
noch die türkische variante zeigt mit zu
marx und mais und so weiter also hab ich
es bei meiner mama gelernt deswegen
türkisch dann schreibt man einfach in
die kommentare und ich zeige euch das
dann einfach irgendwann dem text und ich
freue mich wenn ihr wieder einschaltet
und wird durch ganz viel spaß beim
nachmachen bis dahin tschüss